I told you yesterday that the Trump Ukraine
Biden fiasco is going to become all about
the transcript of the gr 20 July, 2019 phone
call between Trump and the Ukrainian president
and that this is a distraction and exactly
as we discussed yesterday, the white house,
uh, is now going to be putting out a transcript
of that phone call. Now the white house has
a history of doctoring transcripts. The quid
pro quo is unlikely to be evident just from
one phone calls transcript anyway. And the
most part of all of this is that a whistle
blower report is being suppressed. The whistleblower
report about all of this is the most important
thing, not the transcript. So now that Donald
Trump plans to release the transcript, we
need to understand that it will be exactly
what we discussed yesterday.
It's going to be the bar letter 2.0 okay,
so to reset once again in case the details
are becoming murky. The idea here, the claim
is that Joe Biden metaled in the Ukrainian
judicial system to help his son. Now this
is a conspiracy theory for which there is
no evidence and ID bumped it yesterday and
I'm not going to waste your time with it again
today, but what Donald Trump then did is he
went and he pressured the Ukrainian president
reportedly eight times to open an investigation
into Biden in order to smear him. And Trump
has admitted to talking to the Ukrainian president
about Joe Biden. He's admitted that Joe Biden's
alleged corruption was a topic of discussion
during the phone call with the Ukrainian president
and his lawyer, Rudy Giuliani also admitted
this on live television and Donald Trump would
held between 250 million and $400 million
in military aid to Ukraine.
Understood to be over the Biden smear requests.
But that part has not been definitively confirmed.
So now we hear Trump is going to release a
transcript of the call from July, 2019 with
the Ukrainian president. But please understand
what's going to happen here. And I told you
yesterday, it will be just like the bar letter.
Trump is going to release a transcript that
he thinks will help him. Trump lies about
everything. He lies about the size of his
crowds. He lies about the size of his, whatever
he lies about his own intelligence. He lies
about the weather on inauguration day. He
lies about everything. So the transcript that
is released will be muddy enough that it won't
be obvious and overt corruption and quid pro
quo. And that lack of a brazen and obvious
corruption in that one phone call will then
be used by Trump and his defenders to say,
see, look, I told ya, there's nothing to see
here.
They will claim Trump is exonerated by the
transcript. We need the whistleblower report,
but it needs to be given directly to Congress.
The Trump administration should not be allowed
to review and modify the report before it's
given to Congress, which is the direction
things are going in right now. We need the
whistle blower to testify before Congress.
Anything like what is being alleged here,
this pressure on the Ukrainian president,
it would be set up with much more than just
a single phone call in July of 2019 and what
we need to do is not allow Donald Trump to
distract with the transcript. Whatever form
that transcript ultimately takes. Any whistleblower
report released by the white house must be
treated as unreliable and incomplete period.
It will be edited. It will be misleading.
It has to be treated as such by corporate
media. We will see if they actually do treat
it that way, but this is now layer upon layer
of obfuscation and misdirection.
You have initially, uh, you have a whistleblower
who came forward and said, I want to blow
the whistle about this. You then had that
covered with the Joe Biden conspiracy theory,
which is, Hey Joe Biden was there specifically
to make sure that his son doesn't get, doesn't
have a problem because he's working with this
Ukrainian gas company, a blah blah, blah.
We debunked that yesterday. Then on top of
that is the white house coming out and actually
copying to some elements of what's being alleged
about aid being withheld, although they don't
agree as to why it was done, etc. And the
now layer four on top of this, these are just
distraction layers stacked. One on top of
the other is that the transcript is going
to be released and maybe the whistleblower
report in some edited form is going to be
released. We've got to cut through like three
layers of BS here to get what ultimately is
most important, which is a whistleblower report
that is being suppressed period. We are going
to be making a a number of posts about this
story including a poll to the show's Instagram
page, which is at David Pakman show. Make
sure you're following the show on Instagram.
And while you're there,
follow me on Instagram as well. At David dot
pack. You will take a quick break and be back
with so much more right after this